like his predecessor the long-awaited
frozen to is ostensibly a movie for
children but lots of grown-ups are
watching it if anything frozen to
doubles down on bits that seem aimed
squarely at adults he has a look at just
a few of the most memorable the first
frozen film received a fair amount of
criticism for his lack of diversity the
movie's main casts and most if not all
background characters were white
defenders of the film cited the apparent
setting of medieval Scandinavia as the
reason for the whiteness but that excuse
didn't really hold water as a film
setting of arendelle is a fictional
Kingdom and Scandinavia is never
mentioned but Disney was clearly paying
attention to the controversy as frozen
to is certainly more diverse for
starters there is now a prominent black
character lieutenant Matias voiced by
Sterling Kate Brown is an hour in Dalian
soulja who shows up early in the film
and goes on to appear pretty
consistently throughout then the rather
the folder a clan of indigenous people
who live in an enchanted forest and are
pretty central to frozen to story there
based on the real-life Sami people from
Scandinavia and Disney worked with Sami
groups in developing these characters
kids are likely to notice the effort
that went into increasing frozen twos
diversity but adults well despite all
the attention Elsa's sexuality was
seized from fans only Anna has ever
shown any interest in romance in frozen
she spends much of the film pointing
after her suitor Hans then after he
turns out to be the villain she falls
for Kristoff I could I mean I'd like to
I may I
we me I mean may we wait what
we may in frozen - it's made clear from
the get-go that honour is still very
much interested in men or well one man
in particular anna and kristoff are very
much a couple they even casually kissed
from time to time which is kind of an
unusual thing to see in a Disney
animated movie but one scene in
particular makes it seem like anna has
more than kissing on the brain in the
film Anna Kristoff Elsa and Olaf head
else on an adventure together in a wagon
pulled by Sven the reindeer Kristoff and
Anna right together in the front of the
wagon while Elsa and Olaf sit in the
back at a certain point in the journey
both Olaf and Elsa doze off which
doesn't go unnoticed by Anna she points
the situation out to Kristoff and
suggested Lee asks him what he wants to
do before puckering up her lips kids
will think Ghana just wanted a smooch
but adults know that me a smooch doesn't
require privacy or the added danger of
getting caught anyone who's seen frozen
knows Olaf is full of corny jokes kids
may love the Snowman sense of humor
while two adults he can get a little
annoying do you know where she is
yeah why do you think you could show us
the way yeah why this work button frozen
- Olaf actually manages to sneak in a
couple one-liners that are aimed
squarely at the grown-ups and one of
them is actually pretty morbid
there's an old aviation joke regarding
black boxes so-called black boxes if
you're unaware our flight recorders that
are designed to survive a plane crash in
order to help investigators determine
what caused deaths the joke goes
something like this if the black box has
crash proof then why don't they make the
whole plane out of the black box
Olaf tells a variation of this joke in
the movie and he does so at the most
inappropriate moment in the film
elsa and anna find the shipwreck that
killed their parents an unspeakably
tragic discovery upon finding it's one
of them declares that there should be a
record on board in a waterproof box as
that was standard procedure
Olaf then instead of consoling his
friends and it's extremely trying time
asks quote if it's waterproof why didn't
they make the whole ship waterproof kids
will laugh at the joke and not knowing
that it's a reference to a very old joke
about airplanes and that's Olaf is being
extremely insensitive adults meanwhile
may want to see Olaf melt even more than
they already did one of the film's big
reveals comes near the
and when Elsa discovers why arendelle
and the North autre had gone to war in
the past it all started because the king
of arendelle Elsa and Anna's grandfather
was a colonizer who upon discovering the
North ultra secretly formulated a plan
to destroy them why because they
believed in and essentially worship the
magic of the forest these beliefs
differed from his own which frightened
him so he constructed a dam on the river
under the guise of it being a gift and
destroyed their land when caught out on
this but in a folder leader the king
killed him igniting the battle between
the two people frozen to stands on a
number of issues has been clear to
critics the film presents a narrative
that shows the harm done by colonialism
religious bigotry and environmental
recklessness in the end the dam must be
destroyed to lift the curse on the
forest symbolizing a return to the
natural order of things as well as the
destruction of a symbol of oppression
these are heavy themes and since they're
not spelled out in a super obvious
manner kids probably won't understand
the wit of it
with any luck their parents will explain
it to them if there's one thing that
best sums up frozen - it's this love by
itself the movie sends else on a journey
of self-discovery to find the meaning in
her life she's been searching for
forever and she ends up finding herself
the other start of the film Elsa here's
a strange siren song that no one else
can hear this eventually leads her to
the enchanted forest
where she learned to the four spirits of
the forest air wind fire and earth are
in disarray after she learns that she
has the power to tame the spirits she's
told of a mysterious fifth spirit that
acts as a bridge between all the others
Elsa ventures to find this first spirits
the one who's been calling to her since
the start of the film and she ends up in
a temple trying to chase down the
elusive voice when she reaches the end
of the temple she realizes that not only
is she the fifth spirits but she is also
the one she's been searching for her
film's message of self love is an
important one than mud of the viewer and
no matter their age everyone needs to
love and take care of themselves and
everyone even adults can use a reminder
of that from time to time even if is
from a cartoon check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a thing
one
[Music]
[Applause]